I found out that I have a mom it's um
parking too which is a form of
Parkinson's Ozzy Osbourne opening up
about his health struggles the rock
legend and his wife Sharon sat down with
Robin Roberts on Good Morning America to
reveal his diagnosis there's so many
different types of Parkinson's it's not
a death sentence by any stretch of the
imagination but it does affect certain
nerves in your body and it's it's like
you have a good day a good day and then
a really bad day
Ozzy's confession comes just months
after what he calls the most painful and
miserable year of his life the 71 year
old music icon was forced to postpone
all of his 2019 tour dates after
suffering a nasty fall at home and about
with pneumonia on medication Miley's
surgery understand his arm from the
surgery my legs feel going cold the
hardest part for Ozzy he says he misses
being out on the road performing for his
fans
why are you crying right now because it
just means so much to him what he does
he loves to perform me and this is the
longest has ever been home and it's time
for him to get back on the road that's
what's killing me I need you know that's
my drug today the couple's kids Kelly
and Jack Osbourne joined the interview
later Kelly got emotional the hardest
thing is watching somebody that you love
suffer and it's kind of become a bit of
a I think a role reversal for us we have
to all admit what's happening here when
I see my wife gonna let my kids gonna
work everybody's doing 20 helpful to me
that gets me down because I can't
contribute to my family the good news is
that Ozzy says he's a lot better than he
was
last year the couple is planning a trip
in April to see a professor in
Switzerland who deals with getting your
immune system at its peak he's gonna get
back up there and he's gonna do what he
loves to do I know it in 2018 et was
with mr. and mrs. Oh when the metal icon
announced he was taking a step back from
music for The Osbournes family is
everything burn these school events you
can't do it yeah just can't do it all we
have however long were on the last
chapter here of this book and in sight
we don't want to miss any more
[Music]